[Music]
[Applause]
these uh Robert Griffin III or sometimes
referred to as Robert Griffith Jr III
Robert Griffith Jr II thank you MCL ESPN
college football NFL analyst and of
course one the Heisman at Baylor he's
got a podcast it's called RG3 and the
ones with waves Sports entertainment a
unique look at the NFL season through
the lens of a quarterback alongside the
game's best Playmakers good morning
Robert how are you I'm doing great how
you doing Dan I'm doing well uh I still
have your shoes that was either your
prod day or the combine that uh you gave
me the gold ones yeah yes those are from
the combine for sure where we ran a 4-3
and then they autoc corrected it back to
a 44 I'm still holding on to that 4-3
though oh uh last time a team contacted
you about playing uh this offseason so
uh probably August mid August and it's
um who was it I can't tell you who that
was out of respect for for the teams um
but the bottom line is for me I want to
play still I'm enjoying what I'm doing
in the media being one of your
colleagues but if the right opportunity
came along I would certainly um
entertain it and make the right decision
what made you want to start the podcast
what makes it
different um you know just being able to
have a longer Forum you know as you know
with podcasting it's it's not about hot
takes it's not about you know a 30
second clip you get 30 minutes 45
minutes an hour to truly break down the
game have a good time get people to know
you a little bit better and I just
thought that was a safe space for me to
be able to connect uh with the sports
community and celebrate Sports the way
that I think it should be and I want you
to be on the show as well man you're
you're one of the greats in this
business and it would be an honor to
have have you on I'd be more than happy
to uh do that we're talking to RG3 his
new podcast called RG3 and the ones
available wav Sports entertainment let
me hit you with the poll question should
Bill bich be on the hot seat in New
England um Dan I don't think he should
be on the hot seat I know that there's
there's some numbers running out there
about how many wins he needs to to reach
the all time uh record but I do think
that he should get some heat for what
he's done to M Jones um honestly
year two giving M Jones a defensive
coordinator and a special teams coach as
his offensive coordinators is the main
reason M Jones is playing the way he is
right now he had a number six offense in
the league in 2021 with Josh McDaniels
as his offensive coordinator if he would
have just went and got bill o'ban in
year two I think M Jones would have
continued to climb in his trajectory but
because of last year's debacle now M
Jones isn't playing with as much
confidence and I don't think it has
anything to do with the the guys around
him it has a lot to to do with the play
calling and how they've structured it in
2021 they they play action pass 27% of
the time and that's the kind of
quarterback he is he can go through his
reads pure progressions he can do play
action and he can get the ball out of
his hands this year they're doing it 14%
of the time and I don't think anybody's
afraid of their running game and now
you're asking Mt Jones to go out there
and be Patrick Mahomes and create and we
saw what happened when he threw the pick
six uh this past week it's just not a
part of his game that he's ever been
Elite at so I do think that bill
deserves some some heat there because
he's the greatest coach of all time I
know you feel the same way probably in
the NFL but even the greatest coach of
all time can mess it up and he certainly
did with Matt and also free agents don't
want to go there they they wanted to go
there when Brady was there because you
got a chance to win a superow there
there's no reason to go unless you want
to say hey I got to play Under the
greatest coach of all time for one
season but that's it there's no draw
there yeah I mean two years ago they
spent a bol load of money bringing in
free agents uh you know bringing in
tight ends bringing in Matt judon at the
defensive end position and I think to
your point that is why they had to pay
because there was no Tom Brady to lur
guys there to try to win a championship
in their last couple years um Tom is a
is a unique guy and and what's going on
right now with with Bill is really
strengthening the argument that it was
more Tom than it was Bill I still think
that together they really were what what
made the New England Patriots Dynamic
but if you're not going to have Tom
Brady and you're not going to have a
chance to win a championship and you got
to go follow the Patriot Way that
doesn't sound like a lot of fun if you
ask me what did Tom Brady do better than
you oh man when Super Bowls how about
how about what aside from running what
did you do better than
Brady
um wow honestly I don't know if there if
there's really anything because when you
look at Tom
story uh he did face adversity you know
his story at Michigan and and really
biding his time working hard and still
getting replaced uh his his senior year
and having a split time there and then
coming to the NFL being a low draft pick
I think Tom Brady has one of the
greatest stories uh in NFL history with
what he was able to accomplish uh his
ability to process on the field um the
the one thing that I'll say that Brady
had that I didn't early in my career was
a dominant defense and I'm I'm a full
believer in this and I believed it when
I had when I was the Lamar Jackson's
Mentor in Baltimore uh Lamar had a
really good defense to help get him the
ball back to give him more opportunities
to go out and make plays and also just
over the course of the first three years
of his career a defense that he could
truly rely on when the offense wasn't
doing well Brady had the same thing and
I think that allowed Tom to grow into
the player that he eventually became
that didn't need the great defense now
I'm not saying he didn't when he won the
Championships he still had great
defenses but it allowed him to grow and
for me in Washington it was like
everything was on me immediately and I
had to go out there and try to make
magic happen from the start and we did
and it was a lot of fun until I got hurt
um so when you ask me what does Tom
Brady do better than me on the football
field I say just about everything he did
better because he's the greatest of all
time that field that you played on with
Washington was
terrible yeah that was like it was like
sand you know I still remember images of
of like myself and Alfred Morris running
you know from one side of the field to
the other and just sand kicking up
behind us like a Tasmanian devil it was
a really bad field and a lot of guys got
hurt on that field as well but I think
um you know with with Josh Harris and
the group uh they've done everything
they can up to this point to try to
improve the grass there and I know
that's going to be a major point of
emphasis going forward that it never
becomes like that ever again it was
terrible is Joe burrow hurting the
Bengals by playing
o wow that is a that's a tough question
in the in the first game that he played
Dan I believe he helped them from a
standpoint of him being tough and gritty
and putting it on the line for his team
uh and they didn't win that game because
of Joe burrow they won it because Joe
burrow played everyone else raised their
level and there is something to say
about that but when I watched this pass
game oh my my gosh uh Joe Bro doesn't
need to be playing right now he does not
need to be playing he does not need to
be on the field uh he's not healthy his
Mobility is hampered it's hampering the
offense he's not able to move I saw him
scramble on the first drive they had
like a 15-play drive and he scrambled
early in that drive and he took like
three steps and just was like yeah I'm
good and just slid down to the ground
yeah and we were on Monday night
countdown talking about this Dan and and
I got a little you know agitated because
I've been through that you know uh
playing through injury and the risk of
reinjury or a more catastrophic injury
is significantly higher right now for
Joe burrow I just don't want to see him
go through what I did he's one of the
faces of the league uh he's one of the
greatest players we have right now him
getting fully healthy give him four or
five weeks off let him get healthy you
know let the backup go out there defense
play your tail off Jamar Chase T Higgins
all these guys raise their level um
that'll help the Bengals more than
playing Joe burrow right now and who
knows they might go on a winning streak
here I just don't want to see Joe bro
get hurt if you were the Bears and you
would have the number one pick next
year what are you gonna do is there is
it even a
question it is a question D everyone's
like jumping off the Justin Fields uh
boat and I look at it this way we've
seen great quarterbacks struggle early
in their careers we've seen great
quarterbacks play really really well uh
and then and you know year four five six
then they the team starts winning for me
Justin Fields has what 13 games left to
kind of show the Bears that he's the guy
they could have the first pick in the
draft and if Justin Fields throws 25
touchdowns and have and improves his
completion percentage and has a great
qbr I think that would point to them
keeping him and not drafting a
quarterback number one overall but he's
going to have to do that and and I
honestly think that if he does that
they're not going to lose enough games
to be to have the number one pick and I
know a lot of people don't agree with
that take because how Justin fields
looked the first couple games but look
at what he looked like against the
Broncos looked like to me that he
started playing free started looking
like himself again and I know it's the
Broncos everybody's been looking like
World beaters against the Broncos but
let's see if he can build upon that
performance before we just throw the guy
to the Wayside the second best college
quarterback is who oh wow you're saying
second best because obviously you think
the best is Caleb Williams and last time
wrong no I agree with you Caleb Williams
that's my Heisman brother he he is
phenomenal I think we can get spoiled by
his greatness a little bit I think he's
in that category right now uh but the
second best quarterback to me is Michael
pennick Jr uh I call him big pinnick
energy uh he's the second best
quarterback he's the second best I I
gave him that nickname on the broadcast
and let's just say he's using it now to
make money for nil and I'm happy about
that I'm good I'm good with it I I don't
don't bother me at all big
viagr I like so he's he's the second
best QB I always say he's a lefty but he
throws it just right he has every throw
in his bag and I think he went back to
college Dan just to show NFL evaluators
that he can stay healthy you know first
four year of his college career he was
hurt had a season ending injury every
single season but I've called two of his
games in the past two years and I've
I've come come away Beyond impressed he
can do everything you want the
quarterback to do and he reminds me a
lot of Tu a tonga B aloa right now with
the way that he's processing in
college how quickly would you have said
yes if Dion recruited
you yes immediately yeah uh I mean just
think about it Dion's got three things
going for him right and probably more
than that but he was the guy that got
recruited right he's been the parent of
the kid that's getting recruited and now
he's the coach that's recruiting the kid
so he's experienced all those things and
at this point then I don't even think it
matters that he was a Hall of Fame
cornerback I don't think it matters that
I consider him the greatest of all time
at the quarterback position and I know
that's up for debate but that's how I
feel about it the kids don't care about
that they care about what he brings to
the table for them he's allowing these
guys to play free have fun not be afraid
of you know reading your press clippings
which we always were told you're not
supposed to do that then his whole
message is if you read them and you want
them to stay good then go play good and
his guys are rising to the occasion what
he's done at Colorado I know they've
lost two straight but what he's done
there winning three games and playing
USC competitively has been nothing short
of amazing after they won one game last
year so if he had come to recruit me
when I was a high school player for sure
there's no way I'm telling him no but
what if he said I want you to play
defensive back yeah I'm saying
no sorry um didn't Texas do that to you
Texas Texas did they came in I had a one
day offer from Texas Dan a one- day
offer they came in it was uh Spring ball
my senior year they came to the coach's
office his name was Jack Welch that was
our head coach in high school and they
were there to offer our starting
linebacker a kid that was younger than
me named Tanner Brock really good player
um had a brother named Logan Brock that
went to TCU played tight end played in
the NFL for a few seasons and they
offered me as an athlete and I walk in
the office coach says Hey Texas offer
you as an athlete I said hey coach nice
to meet you but I'm a quarterback guy
stormed out and said your offer is off
the table well you know I ended up going
two and one against Texas in my college
time so it all paid off in the end but
there were a few schools that did offer
me as an athlete or a DB or wide
receiver and I just stayed convicted in
the fact that I knew I was a quarterback
well same thing with Manzel wasn't he
asked to be a defensive
back yeah I mean you got to think back
to what Texas was was doing back then
you know playing for national titles uh
always a top ranked team every
quarterback in the state wanted to go to
the University of Texas and they just
felt like they wanted to get the best
athletes to their school but just move
them around to different positions and
they missed on a lot of us I mean
there's a long list of quarterbacks that
they missed on good luck with the
podcast let me know when you want me on
and uh it's great to connect with you
again I appreciate you brother and
remember my name is what was it Robert
Griffith Jr thei yes it is MTH Jun the
thir there you go mcloven we love it
thank you Robert that's RG3 is H first
podcast RG3 and the ones with waves
Sports entertainment and a unique look
at the NFL season through the lens of a
veteran quarterback and some of the
game's best Playmakers